Sulli says I use Apple music Netflix
cloud storage and a few other similar
services and I enjoy the ease of
streaming and it's available ability
wherever I go but I feel stressed from
the payments and subscriptions and
emails in my inbox from these services
man the email stressed me out too like I
feel like any time I yeah give out my
email address even if I you know I will
uncheck that box that has automatically
checked every single time that says it's
yeah please send me updates I'll uncheck
it and somehow I still end up getting a
Tony emails but there's a really easy
solution man you just spam them and
eventually like Gmail takes care of it
it just it will filter all that crap out
yeah I mean you you can you can just
unsubscribe is what I recommend yeah I
mean I spend most of my days in email
just unsubscribing from things I never
subscribed to in the first place I can't
tell you how like I don't know if it's
because of like patreon stuff that I do
or if it's people who just have access
to my my email but I get the most random
solicited stuff man like I nothing
coming to mind right now but like just
stuff that like you said never signed up
for in the first place
yeah I'm imagining someone has my email
address in the league oh yeah Ryan will
appreciate its send me up for word or
something yeah it happens quite a bit so
so I think the first thing is
unsubscribe from the emails you don't
like but if you're feeling stress from
payments I think you have to you have to
work out the math on it right I use
Apple music myself yeah and it's ten
bucks a month I believe I used to spend
way more money than that on music I mean
it was I would spend easily $100 a month
and so I'm saving $90 a month yeah and
so I the the stress that if I were to
feel stress about defending $10 a month
I had to remind myself that I'm not
spending $10 and want I'm saving $90 a
month on that now if you want to go
without music altogether then yeah you
can not buy albums and not subscribe to
a service but in a lot of cases these
end up saving this money I think the
same is true with Netflix I mean Netflix
you know costing less than $20 a month
I mean hell you could you could rent a
few movies from a red box and hey you
have to like take all
time to go out to the red box I think I
assume they still exist yeah okay so so
basically the time that you spent plus I
mean you're getting an unlimited version
of that now the question ultimately is
are you using it yeah right because if
you're not and you're just having it
because everyone else says well you got
to have Netflix well then that's a bad a
bad reason to have it yeah there's some
services to that will like I don't know
the names of them but they'll like go
through and trim up like they'll look at
all your subscriptions and they'll tell
you what you're subscribed to and then
you can just in you can one click and
they'll cancel it for you that's pretty
awesome that's by chance maybe we'll
trim maybe yeah maybe maybe that's trim
com maybe we'll look at it and if we
find look at look it up and if we find
out we'll give it to podcast on to put
in the notes it sounds like an awesome
idea I mean yeah I totally get where
where Lisa's coming from I signed up for
like the live Hulu TV stuff during the
Olympics yeah and then you never
cancelled it never cancelled it and then
literally this month I'm like why the
hell my pain is like I never watch live
TV actually essentially I think I
watched a couple basketball games but
but wasn't worth there for me I could
have went to your house and watch the
basketball games ever I really really
wanted to absolutely but yeah if it's
stressing you out at least you've got to
decide what you're willing to pay for
and what you're not willing to pay for
you know this just goes back to like
minimalism is not easy and it's not
perfect it is simple yeah and simple is
not easy so for a lease they're gonna
have to do some work do some budgeting
really dig into what's important and
then decide what they are gonna keep on
what they're gonna get rid of oh one
other thing I might recommend here is do
a packing party for your streaming
services meaning yeah get rid of them
for a period of time the the experiments
that I've done in the past where I got
rid of TV I got rid of a home Internet I
got rid of my cell phone and then they
all three overlapped at one point you go
to your cell phone yeah yeah for two
months and you learn a special kind of
loneliness when you've gotten rid of
home internet and TV and and the cell
phone you come home and you're like oh
there's just walls here
I guess I'll look out the window wait
look a book
let me see if I still know how to read
and it was although I was talking to the
doctors about this last week it was the
most productive time in my life and then
I realized like I still don't have those
distractions mostly in my life anymore
but I've brought a new distraction in
called podcasts and so now I've
radically limited I went in and deleted
almost all of them and and and that
allows me to say okay if I do miss any
of those that I deleted in the future I
can always bring them back in it's free
to Reese absque Ryba something yeah dude
I love I love the the little stoical
experiments man like I highly recommend
those because like for example your his
cell phone he got rid of for two months
and realized there's like three
payphones in Dayton Ohio they're just
not around anymore yeah and after two
months josh is like oh man you know what
I really that cell phone adds a lot of
value to my life I got to bring that
back in right but it's you know a it
helps you use it differently helps you
look at it differently but it also helps
you realize like yes this is something
that I do need to have ownership over
and so yeah with the streaming services
I think it's a great idea man like a
lease cancel them all and see what you
really really miss and you know if
you're sitting around you're like man I
really wish I had Netflix right now and
then go ahead then sign up for Netflix
and just reactivate nothing else and
kind of yeah just piece it all together
yeah love it
you